is a pack of pills shall learn to the
shortest and the clubs you know you can
use you can you can you can pay yours
what you need to and and life can be a
little bit better for you and when they
raid in my room the police don't look
around like it's just like a Rambo movie
what's going on here there was no
windows in this apartment it was just a
dingy little apartments and shut the
door sat with me back against it
thinking oh yeah
it's always getting banged banged on
it's just a bang bang bang
they've rushed in Army on the floor Face
Down Eyes behind me back a little
Clapper clipping around the back of the
head
and that was you I was arrested
you know and as you thought I said I'm
going down